les acteurs ou au cœur de ce cheval de
Troie comme certains en qualifiés ce
texte car l'expérimentation la
vidéoprotection augmentée pose
d'innombrables problématiques juridique
le respect des libertés et des droits
fondamentaux des personnes mais aussi
technologiques et industrielles qu'elle
s'ouvre intérieure dans la phase de
développement des traitements et qu'elle
assurance pour en limiter les biais et
bien évidemment mes chers collègues
sociétales et politiques vers quelle
société tendons-nous dès lors que
l'anonymat dans l'espace public est levé
et la surveillance globalisée avons-nous
collectivement conscience des
implications d'un tel renversement et y
souscrivons nous quelle garantie
établissons-nous pour nous prémunir
d'éventuelles fuites en avant à cet
endroit je préciserai que l'argument
utilitarisme s'y peut s'il peut
apparaître fondé au regard bien sûr des
menaces sécuritaires ne répondent
nullement à ces questions qui
interrogent pourtant notre cas commun
d’existence j'ajouterai que si cette
solution technologique complète un
arsenal sécuritaire déjà fournie
limite le risque mais ne l'efface pas
pour le dire autrement jusqu'où
sommes-nous prêts à consentir de notre
liberté pour préserver au maximum notre
sécurité
l'article 7 témoigne de cette recherche
d'équilibre particulièrement délicat à
trouver et à cet égard je tiens à saluer
le travail de la commission des lois qui
a mieux encadré le dispositif en votant
le pas à la vie de la CNIL notamment
mais certains points mériteraient
éclairci et pourrait j'espère et
pourront faire l'objet d'amélioration la
durée expérimentation si elle répond au
risque sécuritaire démultiplier pendant
les JO P pourquoi avoir choisi de la
prolonger jusqu'au 30 juin 2025 soit un
an après leur fin l'évaluation de
l'expérimentation étant donné son
importance dans la perspective d'une
éventuelle généralisation doit présenter
toutes les garanties d'indépendance
qu'il est légitime d'attendre enfin
troisièmement l'impact financier sur les
collectivités territoriales et les
organisateurs des manifestations et à ce
jour inconnues l'étude d'impact très
silencieux sur le sujet enfin
quatrièmement et j'arrêterai là
j'aimerais poser une question au
gouvernement pourquoi avoir élargi le
périmètre de l'expérimentation aux
manifestations culturelles et
récréatives j'y reviens alors qu'on pas
trop quand même parce que le texte vous
et quels sont vos motivations je vous
remercie de vos questions
alors Monsieur Philippe Tabarro
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame la rapporteur président buffet
j'interviendrai un petit peu plus tard
lors de la discussion de deux
amendements l'article additionnel
concernant les transports néanmoins je
souhaitais intervenir au préalable pour
vous exprimer ma déception ma déception
car nous sommes en discussion d'articles
et d'amendements intégré au sein du
chapitre 3 nommé renforcer la sécurité
mais de quoi parle-t-on apparemment
seulement de vidéoprotection et de
traitement d'algorithme et c'est bien
mais l'ensemble de nos amendements
visant à renforcer la sécurité dans les
transports ont été déclarés et
recevables au titre de l'article 45 j'en
tire la conclusion suivante renforcer la
sécurité oui mais dans les transports
non et je ne peux pas m'en satisfaire
alors qu'entre 2021 2022 les vols et
violences dans les transports en commun
ont augmenté sans parler du fiasco du
Stade de France nous devons muscler le
continuum de sécurité afin d'enrayer les
incivilités la violence et l'insécurité
qui règne dans nos transports c'était là
connaissance de nos amendements car oui
nous ne dormons pas nous ne donnons pas
suffisamment de moyens aux acteurs de la
sécurité dans les transports à
l'occasion de la lecture du projet de
loi l'homme pile le ministre de
l'intérieur c'était engagé à renforcer
le continuum de sécurité la lecture
restreinte de ce projet de loi témoigne
bien du fait que nous soyons encore loin
d'un tel approfondissement j'espère que
les prochains textes notamment
d'initiative parlementaire permettront
que la peur change en fin de camp
deux amendements identiques de
suppression Monsieur Pierre aux olias
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre cet article 7 il faut dire les
choses de façon claire et du point de
vue du droit et de la défense de l'État
de droit c'est un dispositif qui est des
rocadeurs au rgpd c'est important de le
dire parce que jusqu'à présent la France
en Europe avait été en pointe pour la
défense du rgpd avec cet article 7 nous
reculons sur l'application du rgpd
notamment sur la base de l'article 23 du
rgpd la CNIL a consacré un travail très
important sur les caméras augmentées et
les vidéos augmentées elle a rendu son
avis le 19 juillet 2022 et elle
considère selon elle que par rapport au
rgpd par rapport à un certain nombre de
dispositions qui défendent en France les
libertés individuelles la seule façon
d'autoriser des vidéos c'est de mettre
en place des mesures qui permettent la
suppression je cite quasi immédiate des
images sources ou la production
d'informations anonyme or ce que vous
nous proposez dans ce texte c'est juste
l'information du public en aucun cas
vous vous permettez aux personnes qui
seraient filmées d'avoir un droit de
recours d'avoir un droit d'opposition or
pour la Cnil c'était un objectif tout à
fait essentiel qu'elle souhaitait voir
garantir par une loi spécifique donc
chers collègues il faut bien prendre
conscience que par le biais de cet
article 7 alors qu'il aurait fallu une
loi qui permette de définir aussi les
droits des personnes vous êtes en train
de tout doucement des tricoter le rgpd
merci madame la Présidente
le 63 tomate dessus merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames les ministres j'en
ai déjà longuement parlé lors de la
défense de ma question préalable mais
nous sommes ici face à un cavalier même
je dirais un cheval de Troie législatif
visant à nous faire passer un cap dans
la société de surveillance globale les
Jeux Olympiques et paralympique de
celui-ci qui a un prétexte pour jouer
aux apprentis sorciers avec ses
algorithmes de surveillance nous le
savons le marché est énorme il y a là
plus une opportunité industrielle pour
les entreprises du secteur qu'une
véritable attention à l'ordre public si
c'était l'ordre public qui nous
intéressait nous expérimenterions pas
des technologies absolument pas matures
lorsque nous avons échangé avec Madame
la Ministre des Sports elle m'a affirmé
que l'objectif était d'éviter un nouveau
Séoul en référence au drame ayant fait
plus de 150 morts dans un mouvement de
foule le soir d'Halloween en octobre
2022 mais sachez mes chers collègues que
la Corée du Sud expérimente les caméras
augmentées depuis
2020 ce ne l'a pas empêché ce drame
absolu d'autres raisons sont donc à
trouver mais nous nous mettons nous nous
exposons aussi un risque opérationnel en
effet si le système Noa les forces de
l'ordre sous de faux positives de
notification d'aide à la décision qui se
multiplie on met en danger l'événement
mais nous profitons plutôt de cet
événement exceptionnel pour franchir ce
cap une loi d'exception qui vise à
pérenniser un coup de canif
supplémentaire dans nos libertés
publiques mais ça n'a rien d'inhabituel
puisque que ce soit Rio 2016 ou Tokyo
2020 les gouvernements les différents
gouvernements ont profité des JO pour
faire passer des lois d'exception et
mener des opérations sécuritaires
violentes la CNIL et le Conseil d'État
estime que le déploiement des
dispositifs prévus par l'article 7 dans
des espaces publics présentent
incontestablement des risques pour les
droits et libertés fondamentales
fondamentaux des personnes l'acnil
précise d'ailleurs qu'il est nécessaire
de se prémunir de tout phénomène
d'accoutumance et de banalisation de ces
technologies de plus en plus explosive
c'est pour ça que je vous propose de
supprimer cet article je vous remercie
la vie de la Commission du gouvernement
je vous informe que nous avons reçu une
demande de scrutin public sur ces deux
amendements madame la rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente ce sera un
avis défavorable parce qu'effectivement
nous considérons que cet article 7 qui
est introduit la vidéoprotection
intelligente tous les caméras
augmentaient mettent en place un
dispositif certes d'innovation majeure
mais qui permettra d'aider à la décision
fortement les forces de l'ordre pour la
sécurisation de les grandes
manifestations sportives culturelles et
récréatives et a fortiori dans la
perspective des Jeux Olympiques c'est
une expérimentation c'est JO en seront
un accélérateur mais on voit bien
l'utilité eu égard à la fois au risque
terroristes qui est encore extrêmement
fort dans notre pays et à l'ampleur de
cet événement inédit que seront les Jeux
Olympiques notamment en raison aussi de
la spécificité de la cérémonie
d'ouverture ce dispositif est encadré
par de nombreuses garanties qui ont été
instaurées suite à la réécriture je l'ai
dit après la vie de la je vous conseille
d'État et de la CNIL et nous avons
souhaité encore à la commission des lois
renforcer ses garanties par un contrôle
plein et entier de la CNIL et notamment
par un contrôle au moment de la création
des algorithmes dans les fameux bac à
sable pour faire en sorte que il ne
remplissent pas les billets que vous
évoquez et que le contrôle humain reste
permanent pour s'assurer que ces
algorithmes pourront de déterminer ces
fameuses événements pourront détecter
pardon et signaler ces fameux événements
prédéterminés et aideront nos forces de
l'ordre à être plus efficace et plus
opérationnel pour l'organisation des
grandes manifestations
merci avis du gouvernement
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs en fait
effectivement ce dispositif qui est
prévu est un dispositif novateur c'est
la raison pour laquelle il est engagé de
manière expérimentale l'objectif c'est
de donner au gouvernement les moyens
d'éviter un certain nombre d'événements
alors vous avez parlé sur le sénateur de
ce qui s'est passé à Séoul pour
Halloween on n'a pas aujourd'hui
d'éléments tendant à démontrer que ce
dispositif expérimental a été engagé
dans le cadre de cet événement on a dans
l'histoire d'autres événements de
mouvement de foule qui n'ont pas pu être
détectés c'était le cas à Turin en 2017
c'était également le cas à la Mecque en
2015 d'un événement dans lequel on a eu
plus de 700 morts et donc l'idée c'est
certainement pas on n'a absolument pas
de partie qui concerne des informations
personnelles avec
la reconnaissance faciale par exemple et
le gouvernement s'est appuyé sur cet
article sur le rapport du Sénat qui a
été produit en mai 2022 par les
sénateurs d'oblresses de Bella et Durin
prévoyez quatre catégories dans la
question du traitement algorithmique et
il n'est pas question pour le
gouvernement d'aller dans la quatrième
catégorie qui est souvent cité en
exemple qui est celle de la
reconnaissance faciale mais de se donner
les moyens tout simplement de détecter
le cas échéant des mouvements de foule
un colis abandonné éventuellement des
armes longues etc et donc l'idée c'est
vraiment de se donner les moyens là
d'assurer la sécurité pendant les grands
événements et puis la question de la
durée de l'expérimentation a été abordée
par un certain nombre d'entre vous là
aussi le gouvernement a besoin pour
évaluer ce dispositif d'avoir
suffisamment de grands événements
puisqu'il s'agit bien là de grands
événements à évaluer d'une part et
d'autre part pour entraîner l'algorithme
donc l'idée c'est de se donner
suffisamment de temps donc suffisamment
de grands événements pour pouvoir
évaluer le dispositif donc évidemment le
Gouvernement est défavorable à ses
amendements de suppression
oui une explication de votre au nom de
mon groupe sur
ces deux amendements de suppression
contre lesquels nous voterons nous ne
sommes pas des fanatiques des nouvelles
technologies en matière de surveillance
et d'ailleurs très heureux que la
reconnaissance faciale n'est pas été
proposée dans cette émission parce que
ça n'est pas le bon vecteur ce texte
pour développer la biométrie avec la
vidéo
surveillance augmentée intelligente
algorithmique on l'appellera comme on
veut
c'est vrai qu'on passe à un cap et qu'on
développe dans ce pays pour un événement
qui est lui-même exceptionnel de
nouvelles technologies
nous avons fait le choix
d'accompagner ce mouvement en déposant
de très nombreux amendements
après le premier travail d'encadrement
qui a été produit par la rapporteur
Agnès canaille et qui est déjà très
sécurisant très solide qui vise
notamment à la durée d'expérimentation à
la qualité de l'information du public
à la déclaration d'intérêt des
prestataires extérieurs qui pourraient
être appelés à développer ces systèmes
au périmètre dans lequel c'est système
pour être mis en oeuvre à l'effacement
des données non pertinentes qui auraient
été collectées pour ces systèmes à
l'indépendance des experts qui
contribueront à produire un rapport au
Parlement nous le souhaitons et donc
nous préférons accompagner le
développement de cette vidéo sur
augmenter dans de bonnes conditions avec
un bon niveau d'encadrement dans un
périmètre limité pour que cette
expérimentation nous permet de garantir
que
la puissance publique prend toute sa
responsabilité faute de quoi et nous
aurons le débat bientôt sur d'autres
technologies on risque de voir arriver
cette technologie à bas bruit de manière
rampante hors contrôle législatives
c'est le pari que nous faisons et les
amendements que nous déposerons et nous
défendrons dans quelques minutes
contribueront à nous indiquer si nous
votons favorablement sur cet article 7
ou non
la Présidente
chers collègues vous nous parlez
d'innovation technologique moi ce que je
vois là c'est surtout des innovations du
droit du droit c'est à dire des des
innovations qui qui contribuent à
diminuer ce qui est l'État de droit et
notamment quelque chose qui est tout à
fait fondamental qui est le droit
d'opposition la CNIL vous l'a dit dans
son analyse et le texte n'apporte rien
dans ce domaine il y a simplement une
information qui est donnée mais il y a
pas de droit d'opposition et le droit
d'opposition c'est quelque chose qui est
complètement fondamental dans la gestion
des données numériques je vous le dis de
façon un petit peu un petit peu
provocatrice mais la surveillance à la
chinoise ce n'est vraiment pas notre
tasse de thé et quand on met le doigt
là-dedans on sait pas du tout on
s'arrête et si demain si l'État de droit
et la défense des libertés individuelles
deviennent un obstacle
à l'organisation des grands événements
sportifs alors il n'y aura plus que les
dictatures qui pourront les organiser on
l'a vu récemment avec la Coupe du monde
mais il y aura aussi d'autres exemples
et
bientôt les grandes fédérations pourront
organiser dans des pays qui sont
beaucoup moins regardant sur l'état
droit c'est grandes événements parce que
vous aurez une opposition massive à des
choses qui sont vraiment contraires à ce
que à ce qui est la défense de nos
principes merci Madame présidente
vous avez la parole oui merci madame la
Présidente
je suis
dubitatif depuis quelques minutes
Jeux Olympiques les épreuves de surf
c'est à
une petite commune là sur
Tahiti à 2h 2h30 de voiture depuis
propriété
tous ces dispositifs en matière de
sécurité je suis en train de me poser la
question et je posais la question à mes
collègues autour de moi mais comment
concrètement même à titre expérimental
comment concrètement vous allez faire
appliquer ça sous mes cocotiers enfin
une métaphore certains peuvent être
rigoleront parce que en écoutant tout ça
alors que nous étions enthousiasme et
nous accueillons mais à bras ouverts les
épreuves de surf sur notre territoire
mais depuis tout à l'heure où j'écoute
tout ça je commence à avoir un petit peu
peur maintenant parce que si tout se
dispositif
venait aussi chez nous il y aura plus il
y aurait plus de comment dirais-je une
petite révolution parce que tous ces
soutenaient
encore voté au Parlement
la question que je pose au gouvernement
comment concrètement voyez faire
appliquer tout ça en Polynésie française
ou les épreuves de surf se dérouleront
je remercie notre collègue
polynésien de son intervention qui est
très juste alors ce qui peut paraître
effectivement vraiment flagrant dans
votre territoire il est quand même aussi
dans les notes quelque part parce que
Sylvie Robert l'a très bien dit tout à
l'heure c'est un vrai problème de vision
de la société qui se pose c'est un vrai
problème de vision sécuritaire de vision
contrôlée de vision contrôlée par des
intelligences artificielles
artificielles de
big brother is wattingview qui se pose
réellement aussi pour nous donc
accompagner un mouvement expérimental
certes je comprends ce que dit Jérôme
Durin mais dans la réalité la compagnie
ok mais pour aller où moi je ne suis pas
prêt et nous ne sommes pas prêts à
accompagner un mouvement qui décide un
modèle de société qui ne convient ni à
la Polynésie ni à nos territoires
français c'est pas le modèle de société
que nous souhaitons nous ne
l'accompagnerons pas
s'il n'y a plus d'explication de vote
nous allons donc procéder aux scrutin
public je rappelle que la vie du
gouvernement et de la commission sont
tous les deux défavorables le scrutin
est ouvert le scrutin est l'eau
votez 331 exprimé 331 pour 28 contre 303
le Sénat a donc pas adopté
nous passons à deux amendements commune
le 68 tomates dessus
oui donc cet article qui prévoit un
traitement algorithmique des années des
vidéos de surveillance le fait sur une
durée limitée ce qui pose un certain
nombre de problèmes en termes de liberté
publique alors dans son avis du 8
décembre 2022 la CNIL estime que ses
outils d'analyses automatisés des images
peuvent conduire un traitement massif de
données à caractère personnel ce qui
comporte un risque d'atte à la vie
privée et au droit fondamentaux et
au-delà du caractère scandaleux d'une
expérimentation qui touche nos libertés
publiques on parle d'expérimentation de
ces outils sur une durée donc limitée
mais qu'en est-il réellement loin d'être
une mesure circonscrite au sol Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques ce dont nous
devrions discuter aujourd'hui cette
expérimentation s'étend de la
promulgation de la loi jusqu'à un an
après la cérémonie de clôture des Jeux
chercher l'erreur alors que les jeux ne
sont prévus que sur deux mois on se
retrouve avec l'expérimentation qui dure
2 ans révélant les véritables intentions
du Gouvernement une fuite en avant
techno sécuritaire on veut GAV nos
algorithmes de données l'utilisation de
ces dispositifs dans le simple cadre des
JO et par olympique étant soit
problématique mais de tels délaisse
extensive sont dangereux c'est pourquoi
nous proposons de les ramener à un cadre
temporel plus raisonnable correspondant
à l'intitulé de ce projet de loi
c'est-à-dire la durée des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques
pour par rapport à cette amendement moi
j'estime que Madame le Ministre et
l'intervention de Jérôme Durin ont
défendu cet amendement puisqu'ils ont
expliqué qu'on était dans le cadre d'une
expérimentation mais qui dit
expérimentation dit qu'il y a un début
et une fin donc nous on considère que
c'est assez logique puisque c'est prévu
que l'expérimentation débute dès la
promulgation de la loi parce que ça
permettra comme le disait madame le
ministre d'avoir un certain nombre
d'événements pour expérimenter les
choses et comme nous le disait la
présidente de la CNIL pour pouvoir
affiner et conseiller les fabricants et
les de d'algorithmes mais en même temps
cette expérimentale expérimentation
comme vous l'avez très bien dit madame
la ministre doit servir à évaluer et
pour évaluer à un moment donné il faut
s'arrêter et donc on considère que il
faut s'arrêter après les Jeux Olympiques
pour permettre une évaluation et ne pas
avoir le biais qui peut qui peut
apparaître dans un certain nombre de
propos qu'en fait on aurait le projet de
loi avant même d'avoir évalué alors
évaluons d'abord et puis on verra après
voilà les prix de cet amendement
avis de la commission
merci d'avoir la présence ce sera un
avis défavorable sur ces deux
amendements qui visent à réduire
effectivement le temps d'expérimentation
sur cette vidéo protection intelligente
effectivement qui dit expérimentation
dit durée limitée dans le temps mais qui
dit expérimentation dit aussi évaluation
il faut que l'évaluation elle puisse
être fait dans les mêmes conditions que
la mise en œuvre de l'expérimentation
donc il est important de continuer à
au-delà dans un délai raisonnable de des
Jeux Olympiques pour que les algorithmes
puissent continuer pardon à s'entraîner
et qu'on puisse véritablement évaluer
sur ces données d'apprentissage qui
fonctionnent et sur des algorithmes qui
sont en cours d'utilisation d'une part
et d'autre part il convient aussi
d'étendre l'expérimentation jusqu'à un
délai qui dépasse le temps d'évaluation
pour laisser le temps au Parlement de se
prononcer pour savoir s'il convient de
pérenniser ou non l'expérimentation
sinon elle tombera de fait et qu'il n'y
aura plus lieu que le Parlement se
prononce donc le système proposé
d'expérimentation jusqu'au 30 juin 2025
avec rapport remis 6 mois avant et un
bon équilibre
je vous remercie
madame la ministre
mais ma vie Madame le Ministre ok je
vais donc mettre au voie madame
delagonie pour une explication de vote
et puis pierre au zodia s'apprête
merci madame la Présidente j'attendais
avec beaucoup d'intérêt l'explication du
gouvernement parce que
non mais je vois bien que vous fiez à la
vie de la rapporteur mais dans ce cas là
ce n'est même plus la peine d'occuper le
banc du gouvernement
qui n'est pas d'accord
non plus sérieusement
on est sur un point qui est essentiel
qui est la durée de cette prétendue
expérimentation et ce que beaucoup
appellent le cheval de Troie
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait au prétexte de
l'expérimentation vous mettez en place
pendant deux ans un dispositif qui n'est
pas nécessaire pendant deux ans
d'ailleurs si vous voulez entraîner les
algorithmes puisque j'ai compris que
c'était ça le terme
il y a la Coupe du monde de rugby donc
vous avez tout loisir d'expérimenter les
dispositifs bien j'indique tout de même
que en fonction du sort qui sera réservé
à nos amendements sur ce point même si
la rapporteur a travaillé et la
Commission a travaillé de manière
extrêmement précise et complémentaire et
améliorer le texte notre groupe sera
amené à modifier le vote sur l'ensemble
de cet article donc encore une fois
madame la ministre moi je suis un esprit
simple je ne comprends pas comment par
quel raisonnement il faut prolonger
pendant deux ans une expérimentation
pour pouvoir l'évaluer donc c'est sur ce
point et sur la nécessité de cette
prolongation un an après les JO que je
souhaiterais pouvoir connaître la
position du gouvernement carrossolias
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre ce que ce que vous nous
demandez de voter ici c'est un cavalier
c'est un cavalier législatif là ce soir
on est réunis pour voter un texte qui
prévoit des mesures exceptionnelles pour
le bon déroulement des Jeux Olympiques
prolonger au-delà de la durée de jeux
olympiques l'expérimentation que vous
proposez c'est tout simplement un
cavalier législatif et le Conseil
constitutionnel aura sans doute à se
prononcer sur sur ce que vous faites si
vous souhaitez une loi qui permette par
des procédés algorithmiques aujourd'hui
de développer des systèmes de protection
et de sécurité dans ces cas-là vous
déposez un projet et on n'en dépatera
mais vous pouvez pas utiliser ce texte
sur les Jeux Olympiques pour avancer
toute votre machinerie sur sur la
gestion algorithmique des populations
encore une fois je vous le dis avec avec
force et solennité madame la ministre ce
qu'il s'agit de défendre c'est
l'acceptabilité sociale des Jeux
Olympiques si nos citoyens ont
sentiments que quand un pays organise
les Jeux Olympiques c'est matière à
problèmes de circulation problème de
santé problème de transport problème de
congés et aussi problème de sécurité
encore une fois il refuseront
systématiquement les Jeux Olympiques et
Paris sera la dernière ville qui les
organisera merci madame la présidente
Sylvie Robert
oui merci madame la Présidente oui
madame ministre moi je voudrais que on
soit quand même extrêmement
attentif à à cette expérimentation que
d'aucun d'ailleurs ont qualifié de
changement de paradigme même
civilisationnel donc je ne suis pas du
tout
convaincu par la rapporteur qui nous dit
il faut prolonger parce qu'il faut
évaluer pour que les que les algorithmes
s'entraînent alors moi je vais lui poser
une question très simple c'est que
jusqu'au à 2025 qu'est-ce qu'il va y
avoir comme manifestation qui vont
permettre
d'entraîner ces algorithmes parce que
quand même la cohérence intellectuelle
voudrait que nous fassions
l'expérimentation nous arrêtions
l'expérimentation juste à la fin des
Jeux Olympiques qu'ensuite on évalue
qu'en fonction de l'évaluation après
bien sûr on revienne devant le Parlement
pour voir s'il y a généralisation il y a
quelque chose que je ne comprends pas et
tout à l'heure pardon madame la
Présidente vous m'avez à juste titre
coupé dans ma parole sur article j'étais
trop longue et j'avais demandé à la
ministre pourquoi est-ce que on est on
est temps au manifestations sportives
culturelles et récréatives cette
expérience moi j'aimerais avoir la
réponse parce que je peux vous dire
qu'après les débats que nous avons eu le
miloculturel et là j'ai un certain
nombre de messages n'est pas du tout
rassuré des débats que nous avons eu sur
le sujet donc je crois que c'est
vraiment important que vous puissiez
madame linis nous donner vraiment des
précisions et des explications sur ces
amendements du Bénin roche
oui madame la présidente madame la
ministre nous ne souhaitons pas cette
expérimentation pour les raisons que
nous avons déjà évoqué ou que d'autres
ont fait ici mais en commission des lois
j'étais déjà eu l'occasion de le dire
exactement comme pierre ou Julias en
fait si un fort retourné si c'était
sénateur qui avait proposé parce que ça
n'était pas dans le texte d'augmenter la
période d'expérimentation
un an ou deux ans après les Jeux
Olympiques on aurait déclaré notre
amendement il recevable c'est le texte
qu'il est irrecevable pour nous c'est un
vrai cavalier législatif le vrai
cavalier législatif qui consiste à
changer un certain nombre de règles de
notre droit concernant la sécurité
lors du passage ici au Parlement de loi
sur les jeux olympiques et le résultat
en dehors de changer le paradigme il est
très clair c'est que dans quelques
années au cas aucune ville aucun pays du
monde sauf les dictatures seront
capables d'organiser des Jeux Olympiques
et merci sur la question de du cavalier
très clairement la question du
traitement des mouvements de foule dans
l'organisation de ces Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques étaient au cœur des
préoccupations du gouvernement donc là
le traitement de de cet article répond
justement à cette préoccupation là
ensuite sur la question de la durée ça a
été très bien expliqué c'est pour ça que
je m'en suis remise à l'avis de leur
rapporteur la question de
l'expérimentation c'est d'avoir le
maximum de données pour pouvoir faire
une évaluation et je rappelle que le
rapport sera remis 6 mois avant la fin
de la période expérimentale et d'avoir
le terrain le plus large possible et le
et on parle exclusivement de grands
événements donc il est clair que il nous
faut une certaine durée pour pouvoir
pour pouvoir évaluer correctement le
dispositif ensuite sur la question de
l'élargissement aux manifestations
culturelles et récréatives c'est une
demande du Conseil d'État qui a souhaité
là aussi pour élargir le plus possible
et pour permettre d'avoir une évaluation
la plus claire possible rajouter aux
manifestations sportives qui avaient été
proposées initialement par le
gouvernement les manifestations
culturelles et récréatives
merci je vais donc mettre au voie ses
amendements qui ont tout de recherche
le 68 qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient à n'est
pas adoptée le 21 qui est pour qui
contre qui s'abstiennent n'est pas
adopté lequel nous passons 44 monsieur
fialer qu'il
oui madame la présidente Madame le
Ministre
le mécanisme que nous examinons ici n'a
rien à dodain puisqu'il s'agit
d'autoriser l'utilisation de traitement
algorithmique en matière de vidéo
surveillance les bouleversements
qu'introduisent cette expérimentation
déjà été soulignée d'ailleurs la
commission des lois en a conscience
puisque le texte qu'elle nous présente a
déjà intégré des mécanismes de contrôle
supplémentaire dans cette perspective
nous permettons de rappeler la prise de
position de la CNIL qui souligne que les
conditions d'application à cette
nouvelle technologie des règles
relatives à la protection des données et
des principes protégeant les droits
fondamentaux sont en partie incertaine
ou à construire de sorte que face aux
incertitudes nous croyons que ce
dispositif doit être strictement limitée
et encadré l'article introduit deux
conditions retenues alternativement pour
que le dispositif puisse être engagé
l'ampleur ou les circonstances de
l'événement seulement comme nous ne
savons pas comment seront interprétés
ces critères des administrations et les
juges peut-être serait-il raisonnable
dans un premier temps de renforcer ces
critères aussi l'amendement proposé
propose d'en rajouter un troisième le
caractère exceptionnel de l'événement
avec une telle condition par exemple les
rencontrer hebdomadaires des
compétitions nationales de football ou
de rugby serait exclu en revanche des
machesix des matchs exceptionnels tels
que la réception Stade de France de la
Ligue la finale de la Ligue des
Champions en mai dernier aurait pu
rentrer dans ce dispositif
la commission
avis défavorable à la présidence nous
comprenons la volonté de sécuriser au
maximum et c'est ce qu'on a tenté de
faire à la commission des lois mais
encore faut-il que ce soit opérationnel
et l'événement exceptionnel ce ne sont
pas forcément ces événements là qui sont
ceux pour lequel il y a le plus de
risques on peut penser au marché de Noël
au marathon au 14 juillet etc donc on
pense que véritablement rajouter cette
condition là ne permettra pas de rendre
opérant ni de couvrir l'ensemble des
événements auxquels sont destinés la
vidéoprotection intelligente avis du
gouvernement
avis défavorable du gouvernement
effectivement comme ça a été dit par la
rapporteur le caractère exceptionnel est
pas toujours celui qui manifeste le
risque réel c'est à dire qu'on a des
manifestations qui sont régulières mais
qui pour par leur caractéristiques
particulières nécessite ce type de
dispositif et qui sont pas forcément
exceptionnels donc le rajouter
limiterait le champ le champ des
possibles et donc avis défavorable du
gouvernement je mets aux voix donc la
vie défavorable qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'absède n'est pas
adopté le 43 Bernard FEDER
cet amendement pour tuer les mêmes
objectifs que le précédent c'est-à-dire
renforcer les contours juridiques du
recours aux algorithmes pour endimiter
l'usage et donc pour y parvenir nous
proposons de rendre cumulative les deux
conditions d'ampleur et de circonstances
qui permettent de désigner un événement
on voit bien quand les proposants
alternativement les limites seront très
difficiles à tracer on trouvera toujours
une circonstance pour dire qu'il fallait
activer le positif je pense donc qu'il
faut avancer prudemment et
progressivement et donc limiter tout
risque d'excès en faisant se cumuler
l'ampleur et les circonstances
défavorables c'est le même raisonnement
que l'amendement précédent gouvernement
même ma vie je mets aux voix double vie
défavorable qui est pour qui contre qui
n'est pas adopté le 60 Thomas dessus
merci madame la Présidente nous sommes
très attachés à la notion d'héritage de
ces JO nous souhaitons que ces JO
laissent une trace pérenne dans notre
pays mais nous n'acceptons pas la
politique du pied dans la porte nous
n'acceptons pas que dans l'héritage il y
a dans le l'héritage lié à la société de
surveillance nous ne pensons pas qu'il y
a de nécessités absolues à déployer
cette technologie nous ne sommes pas
dupe il y a dans la démarche
expérimentale que nous propose ici un
moyen d'habituer la population à cette
nouvelle étape de la surveillance
globale premier problème du traitement
algorithmique des images issus de la
vidéo surveillance tant le Conseil
d'État que la CNIL considère que ces
traitements algorithmiques représentent
une menace pour les droits fondamentaux
des individus d'après la CNIL ces outils
ne constituent pas une simple évolution
technologique comme on essaie de nous
vendre depuis tout à l'heure mais une
modification de la nature des dispos une
vidéo pouvant entraîner des risques
importants pour les libertés
individuelles et collectives et un
risque de surveillance et d'analyse dans
l'espace public la CNIL précise au
passage qu'il est nécessaire d'empêcher
tout phénomène d'accoutumance et de
banalisation de ces technologies seconds
problèmes l'utilisation des systèmes
d'intelligence artificielle est
aujourd'hui dépourvu de cadre légal
propre dans le droit national comme dans
le droit de l'Union européenne une
proposition de règlement européen sur
les systèmes d'intelligence artificielle
est en cours d'élaboration mais rien
n'existe à l'heure actuelle nous ne nous
l'aurons pas devant l'objectif à peine
volet du gouvernement détendent la
portée de ses dispositifs par le droit
la durée extensive de l'expérimentation
dont nous venons de débattre et le
contenu du texte sont autant de preuves
de la volonté de pérenniser ces
expérimentations parce que nous refusons
la banalisation de ces dispositifs
sécurité face au risque des dérives
potentiels et dans l'attente d'une
actualisation de la réglementation
européenne nous proposons donc
d'inscrire expressément dans la loi que
cette expérience n'a pas à être
pérennisé
quelle est la ville de la Commission
à vie défavorable effectivement
il faudra nécessairement une loi pour
assurer la pérennisation de
l'expérimentation donc en aucun cas ça
ne se fera de manière automatique donc
en fait votre amendement est satisfait
gouvernement
même avis effectivement le principe le
gouvernement a opté pour le principe de
l'expérimentation qui donnera lieu à une
évaluation et donc un passage le cas
échéant devant le Parlement pour pour
une pérennisation mais je rappelle
également que quand même ce texte suit
les préconisations de la CNIL d'une part
et d'autre part que la CNIL sera informé
des conditions de mise en oeuvre de ce
dispositif et je rappelle également que
le dispositif est sur la base des
préconisations de la CNIL pardon soumis
à des garanties extrêmement fortes des
garanties en matière d'une part du fait
que cette expérimentale d'autre part que
c'est utilisable uniquement pendant les
grands événements d'autre part que il y
a des garanties sur l'utilisation du
logiciel en matière d'information du
public en matière de conservation des
données en matière de contrôle humain en
matière de formation des agents et ça a
fait l'objet d'un amendement de la
rapporteur adopté en commission à des
garanties également sur les algorithmes
avec un décret qui est pris après avis
de la CNIL avec une garantie qui prévoit
que seul l'état puis réaliser un tel
dispositif et puis je le rappelle à une
garantie parce que c'est bien le préfet
qui détermine en fonction de la
manifestation du territoire géographique
et d'un certain nombre d'éléments si oui
ou non ce dispositif peut être utilisé
donc toutes ces garanties permettront
d'une part permettre d'une part de
cadrer le dispositif d'autres parts de
d'avoir une expérimentation la plus
efficace possible
une explication de vote
et oui juste un mot français qui dit ça
échaudé crée l'eau froide
la rapportrice de devrait savoir de quoi
je veux parler en fait c'est pas idiot
de dire que ça peut pas automatiquement
être généralisé parce qu'en fait il y a
certains d'orbes d'expérimentation qui
ont été généralisées avant l'évaluation
les cours criminels départementales
c'est cette année on est un exemple on a
généralisé la cour criminelle
départementale une expérimentation avant
même qu'elle soit évaluée et d'ailleurs
si on l'avait évalué avant on l'aurait
peut-être pas généralisé donc le fait de
préciser que c'est pas automatique
ça me paraît une bonne idée il est
précisé à l'alinéa 28 du présent article
que dans certains cas le public pourrait
ne pas être informé de l'usage de caméra
dite augmentée qu'est-ce qui pourrait
bien légitimer une telle exception
monsieur le ministre qu'est-ce qui
justifierait que les citoyens et les
citoyens ne puissent pas avoir accès à
des informations relatives à leur droit
et libertés visiblement nous ne sommes
pas les seuls à trouver que les
situations qui relèveraient de cette
exception manque de clarté la CNIL
elle-même s'interroge sur les hypothèses
dans lesquelles une telle exclusion
s'avérait nécessaire elle recommande
d'ailleurs que les conditions
justifiantes soient particulièrement
limitée or en l'état aucune précision à
ce sujet n'a été formulée par ce projet
de loi la CNIL estime dans son rapport
sur le projet de loi que l'information
des personnes de l'usage des caméras
augmenté est je cite un élément
essentiel pour assurer la loyauté des
traitements dans un objectif de
transparence à l'égard du public et
qu'elle est indispensable pour permettre
le déploiement des dispositifs dans un
climat de confiance à l'égard des
autorités publiques au groupe écologiste
nous considérons que l'information du
public est une garantie essentielle de
la protection des droits et libertés des
personnes et notamment du droit à la vie
privée comment faire valoir ses droits
d'opposition d'accès de rectification et
d'effacement de ces données personnelles
si on ne sait même pas que ces données
existent à ce titre nous proposons par
cet amendement la suppression de cette
dispense d'information du public de
l'usage des dites augmenter
merci chers collègues le 25 rectifié
monsieur du Rhin
ah pardon excusez-moi chers collègues
merci madame la Présidente donc c'est
une discussion commune mais l'esprit est
différent nous on vous propose de
compléter le travail
utile de la commission qui a introduit
une garantie supplémentaire pour assurer
l'information du public sur l'emploi du
traitement des données personnelles
prévues par cet article 7 y compris
lorsque les circonstances l'interdisent
ou que cette information entre en
contradiction avec les objectifs
poursuivis par le traitement donc dans
ces cas la Commission a prévu de
renvoyer à une information générale
organisée par le ministère de
l'Intérieur je fais référence au
paragraphe 2 bis nouveau inséré à
l'article 7 et si nous voulons que
l'information du public soit pleinement
appliquée il convient de prévoir
également dans la décision
d'autorisation d'emploi prise par le
préfet des départements ou le préfet de
police à Paris que les motifs de
dispense d'information du public soit
accompagnés un minimum de l'information
générale du public sur l'emploi du
traitement algorithmique cette
information nous semble essentielle car
elle conditionne le cas échéant la
possibilité d'invoquer le respect du
droit de personnes à l'égard de la bonne
application de ces traitements de
données personnelles
augmenter par l'intelligence
artificielle sur le fondement du rgpd et
de la directive police justice merci si
chers collègues avis de la commission
merci d'avoir la présidente alors sur
l'amendement 62 du sénateur dossus ce
sera un avis défavorable pense que
supprimer la possibilité d'exception au
droit de l'information affaiblirait le
dispositif et le rendrait beaucoup moins
opérationnel et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avions quand même en
commission des lois ajouté une garantie
sous la forme d'une information générale
du public sur l'emploi des traitements
algorithmiques organisés par le
ministère de l'Intérieur pour informer
les publics des enjeux concernant cette
vidéoprotection intelligente donc ce
sera un avis défavorable sur le 62 sur
le 25 de Monsieur Durin qui renvoie à
cette information en général organisée
par le ministère de l'intérieur c'est un
avis favorable
merci madame le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre oui madame la Présidente un
avis défavorable sur le premier
abonnement et un avis on va dire
réserver monsieur du rabais je vais
essayer de vous expliquer pourquoi je
pense qu'il y a une je crois une petite
confusion me semble-t-il sur pourquoi on
informe les citoyens selon la volonté de
la CNIL et de la volonté du législateur
qui sont vidéo protégés aux vidéos
surveillées le terme que vous souhaitez
on a eu ce débat pendant la sécurité
globale sur d'autres sujets que les
caméras de vidéoprotection c'est
effectivement comme vous l'avez très
bien dit pour pouvoir être informé
consulter les données personnelles qui
nous concernent et puis évidemment si on
le souhaite faire effacer ces données ce
n'est pas pour être empêché d'abord
d'être filmé bien évidemment chacun le
comprend
mais l'intelligence artificielle
appliquée aux caméras de vidéoprotection
appliquer aux captation d'images ne vise
pas à donner des éléments
supplémentaires de surveillance des
individus mais des situations que pourra
faire très concrètement cette caméra dit
intelligence d'intelligence artificielle
elle pourra regarder quelle est
l'événement que nous souhaitons
retrouver ou la situation que ce sont
retrouvées le comportement que ce sont
retrouvés à rassemblement extrêmement
intempestif
casse d'abribus un sac posé par terre il
ne visera pas à rechercher monsieur
dessus monsieur Darmanin ou monsieur
Durand il ne s'agit donc pas pour la
personne pour le citoyen
individuellement de pouvoir retrouver
des données qui lui sont personnelles
mais l'intelligence ça c'est la caméra
si je veux dire classique qu'il le fait
et qui le fait de manière générale et
c'est pour ça qu'il me semblait que la
vie était réservée pour votre amendement
et finalement si j'ose dire il ne mange
pas de pain votre amendement c'est pour
ça que je le combat pas plus que ça et
sans doute laisse la vie positive qui a
donné comme la rapporteur mais
l'information générale elle est déjà
donnée par le ministère de l'intérieur
soit par les communes lorsqu'il s'agit
de caméra ou l'état pour la préfecture
de police évidemment de caméra déjà
installées chacun doit installer des
panneaux publier dans le journal
municipal la présence de ces caméras y
compris mobile et tout autre type
d'information on a eu cette discussion
pour les aéronef et pour d'autres
situations comme les drones dans la loi
sécurité globale mais en aucun cas
l'intelligence artificielle rajoute quoi
que ce soit puisque il ne peut pas y
avoir il ne peut pas y avoir de
captation
sans caméra donc cette information est
déjà donné par la loi et l'intelligence
artificielle vise à retrouver des
situations suite été extrêmement
différents si vous avions proposé la
reconnaissance faciale qui est là parle
de sujet individuel et donc évidemment
l'information autour des données
individuelles retrouvées par ce moyen
nouveau même dans un moyen de captation
ancien aurait sans doute eu son sens de
discussion donc vraiment je pense qu'il
faut bien comprendre pour ceux qui nous
qui ne s'agit pas dans l'intelligence
artificielle de continuer à regarder des
données personnelles ce n'est pas ce que
feront ces
caméras
c'est des situations mais comme chacun a
dû le voir sans doute dans des
documentaires dans des films ou dans des
reportages ou dans les auditions vous
avez pu faire et c'est situation sont
extrêmement importantes imaginons que
nous ayons à gérer une alerte à la bombe
pour savoir si elle est sérieuse pas
sérieuses qui a déposé le sac dans
quelles conditions il a déposé un sac
est-ce que cette situation de
déposstacle c'est un oubli ou c'est
quelqu'un qui le fait d'ailleurs
volontaire ça fait gagner énormément de
temps au service de police qui l'a
déposé en tant que tel ou les personnes
autour d'elle ne sont pas concernés par
les algorithmes et par la finalité que
nous demandons législateur je constate
d'ailleurs monsieur dessus que et la vie
de la CNIL et la vie du Conseil d'État
sur un texte aussi complexe ont été sans
réserve sur cette situation et les
débats qu'on a eu précédemment et
notamment sur la locmise sur les
questions d'image on est tous été
validés vous l'aurez constaté par une
exc une décision du Conseil
constitutionnel dont je me réjouis donc
je veux vraiment ici dire et j'en salue
le rapporteur Hervé qui a notamment
évoqué ces sujets de données
personnelles je vais aussi dire encore
une fois que la Haute Assemblée rejetée
la maman de Monsieur dessus pour
confusion si je vous permets et voilà la
maman de ce Durin sans doute est
superfétatoire mais je veux bien donner
un avis neutre c'est à dire réservé pour
l'adoption
c'est une sagesse monsieur le ministre
un avis défavorable
sagesse neutre bon bah écoutez nous
innovons aujourd'hui mais bon alors je
mets au bois ah pardon monsieur dessus
pour explication de vote et Madame
arrivée merci madame la Présidente là on
constate qu'on est en train de reculer
sur sur un centre de droit
lié à nos données à nos comportements
vous venez de le dire ces caméras enfin
ses caméras elles existent elles sont
déjà là on va les on va leur ajouter un
système qui va permettre de faire la
différence entre différents
comportements différentes situations
qu'est-ce qui nous fait basculer dans
une société de surveillance c'est qu'un
comporte un individu vous moi un autre
va se trouver dans une situation sans
savoir ce que la caméra va chercher à
contrôler dans son comportement vous
l'avez cité un oubli de sac alors vous
vous êtes rattrapé en disant que ce sera
pas une donnée personnelle mais que ça
peut faciliter quand même d'identifier
la personne qui l'a oublié donc on est
déjà en train de reculer un peu
là-dessus bien sûr que si on est en
train déjà reculer sur quels sont les
comportements acceptés quelles sont les
commencements non acceptés qui
définissent ça effectivement là on le
sait pas ça sera défini dans les
algorithmes que vous n'avez pas voulu
ouvrir donc on est en train de reculer
sur un certain nombre de de droits et
liberté et de la façon dont on peut nous
individus protester contre la collecte
d'assentes de données ensuite monsieur
minet je vous trouve extrêmement
rigoureux sur le la question des droits
et libertés vous l'aviez été le 22
octobre devant nous quand vous aviez
présenté le dispositif de sécurité vous
aviez dit le ministère de l'Intérieur
n'utilisera pas de dispositifs
illégaux qui n'ont pas été réaliser mais
par contre un certain nombre de
collectivités les utilisent déjà ce sont
vos mots là-dessus vous n'aviez pas
répondu ensuite à savoir quelles sont
les collectivités qui utilisent tout ça
quelle est l'action du ministère
intérieur pour lutter contre l'usage
abusif de cette technologie on a déjà pu
voir un centre de marché public passé
pour des technologies qui ne sont pas
encore légalisées et donc j'aimerais
bien avoir réponse aussi là-dessus vous
qui êtes si respectueux du droit merci
chers
simplement pour dire que cet amendement
que nous proposons et qui a été qui a un
avis favorable de leur rapporteur c'est
pas quelque chose qui qui est anodin non
plus c'est à dire que c'est il s'agit
pas d'une information individualisée
mais il s'agit de lier la décision à
l'information c'est tout et donc je
pense que ça permet plus de transparence
ça permet d'être plus clair alors vous
avez dit ça mange pas de pain je crois
que non en tout cas mais en tout cas ça
ça fixe ça fixe les choses et ça
officialise cette dimension de
l'information du public
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
je veux pas laisser monsieur dessus mais
très rapidement faire croire que Missa
intérieur connaîtrait des situations
illégales interviendraient pas
non mais je suis respectueux je suis
surtout respectueux la Constitution
monsieur sénateur et en tant que
représentant des collectivités locales
vous seriez très Sourcieux que l'article
72 de la Constitution soit respecté par
le ministre de l'intérieur c'est à dire
que ces gens ont une compétence propre
ne vous en déplaise des communes que de
gérer la sécurité de leurs concitoyens
en ce qui concerne la célébrité publique
la tranquillité publique et les caméras
de vidéoprotection et je pense qu'à un
certain nombre d'élus écologistes qui
serait bien inspiré d'appliquer les
règles de la République législateur
l'aura accordé mais c'est un autre débat
c'est un autre débat on connaît quelques
quelques collectivités locales qui en
font eux-mêmes revendications d'ailleurs
on voit que c'est souvent là où la
délinquance est parfois la plus
importante on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler si vous le souhaitez mais c'est
un autre c'est un autre débat il
appartient justement il appartient
justement au tiers de confiance évoquée
par votre collègue communiste que de
faire ses contrôles et je sais que la
CNIL y est particulièrement attentif
donc ce n'est pas au ministère de
l'Intérieur que de fait apporter une
tutelle ça n'existe plus depuis 1981 ça
n'existe plus 1980 donc il faut être
respectueux de la Constitution et
l'héritage mitterrandien
alors Monsieur Durin vous avez la parole
une explication de votre non pas pour
allonger les débats mais pour préciser
un point de vue politique très très cher
à notre groupe au coeur de ce débat
l'argument de notre collègue dessus
s'entend parfaitement on comprend les
réserves que son groupe peut avoir d'où
d'ailleurs des d'émotions préalables
nous considérerons pour ce qui nous
concerne qu'il existe un risque
deux développements rampants à bas bruit
d'un certain nombre de technologies et
quand nous proposons qu'on puisse en
tant que législateur s'intéresser à ces
sujets fixer un cadre c'est pas pour
autoriser ces technologies c'est
précisément pour dire dans quelles
conditions alors même qu'elle s'invite
partout dans nos vies personnelles et
collectives à quelles conditions on peut
les utiliser et pour avoir travaillé ça
a été rappelé plusieurs fois dans la
journée avec Arnaud de belnay et Marc
Philippe de Brest sur la reconnaissance
faciale on voit bien qu'en plus qu'il y
a une porosité des usages c'est à dire
que les citoyens consommateurs
autorisent dans leur comportement
individuel dans le comportement
personnel des choses qu'il réfutent en
tant que citoyen vis-à-vis de l'État et
du coup il faut quand même résoudre ces
tensions donc quand on propose de
légiférer de poser un cadre de définir
de nid rouge de temps en temps
d'autoriser des expérimentations et
c'est la démarche que notre groupe
l'espèce s'agissant de la vidéo
surveillance intelligente c'est pas par
plaisir de permettre tout et n'importe
quoi c'est au contraire pour que le
cadre dans lequel ces technologies sont
développées soient respectueux des
libertés voilà donc c'est vraiment
l'esprit qui nous anime et d'où les
amendements que nous avons déposé pour
que l'information soit claire que les
périmètres soient fixés que les durées
soient limitées que les durées de
conservation soient elles-mêmes limitée
et qu'on puisse avancer ensemble dans la
confiance vers l'usage de cette
technologie merci chers collègues il n'y
a plus de demande de parole je vais donc
mettre aux voix tout d'abord
l'amendement 62 qu'a reçu deux avis
défavorables qui est pour
[Musique]
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté et le
25 rectifié qui a reçu un avis favorable
de la commission et une sagesse
neutre du gouvernement qui est pour
qui contre il est adopté
nous passons à l'amendement 26 monsieur
Durin
alors on va connecter beaucoup de
données des données qui sont utiles
d'autres qui ne le sont pas ce que nous
souhaitons au travers de cet amendement
c'est de préciser expressément que les
données qui ne sont qui sont considérées
comme non pertinentes non adéquates et
non représentative puisse être
immédiatement supprimés sans attendre
l'expiration du délai autorisé en
commission madame la rapporteur nous a
fait observer que cette mesure est
satisfaite mais il nous semble qu'elle
apparaît pas clairement dans le
dispositif de l'articles 7 qui au moment
où nous parlons est encore au stade de
l'expérimentation s'agissant d'adopter
pour la première fois un dispositif
inédit on l'a vu qui est porteur
d'enjeux nouveau pour les droits
libertés qui est sensible le scénario
d'obéir à ce que figure dans la loi les
principes essentiels qui déterminent
l'usage des caméras augmentées c'est
d'une condition qui pour nous est
essentielle
il nous semble qu'elle doit être
explicitement mentionnée le président de
la CNIL d'ailleurs vient de s'exprimer
sur le sujet et à rappeler que le
principe de base de cette application
est conservé le moins longtemps possible
les données si la CNIL veillera à ce que
les données soient supprimées
lorsqu'elles doivent être autant
inscrire dans le corps de la loi
madame leur rapporteur avis de la
commission oui merci à la présidente ce
sera un avis défavorable il a été il
était satisfait puisque ces données sont
immédiatement détruites dès lors que
elle elle devrait pas exister pardon
donc on voit pas l'intérêt de le
rajouter dans le texte
je mets au voile amendement 26 qui a
reçu deux avis défavorables qui est pour
qui est contre qui n'est pas adopté le
monsieur Redon Sarrasi la Présidente
nous souhaitons lever une ambiguïté qui
existe dans le texte entre deux notions
qui peuvent converger mais qui ne se
confondent pas la pluridisciplinarité et
l'indépendance c'est une bonne chose de
prévoir que plusieurs spécialistes
s'associent pour procéder à l'évaluation
des caméras augmentées chacun
travaillant dans son champ d'application
ou sa discipline avec la méthodologie
qui lui est propre nous sommes tout à
fait favorables à cette optimisation des
approches pour tirer les meilleures
conclusions de l'expérimentation
cependant prévoir la meilleure
communication possible entre les savoirs
ne garantit pas l'indépendance du
rapport final c'est la raison pour
laquelle conformément à la
recommandation de la CNIL nous
souhaitons préciser que l'évaluation de
l'expérimentation soit conduite en
association avec des experts
indépendants
merci chers collègues madame la
rapporteur
ce sera madame la Présidente un avis
défavorable nous pensons effectivement
que c'est déjà prévu que ce soit des
personnes alitées au caractère
pluridisciplinaire qui a qui fasse
l'évaluation pardon de l'expérimentation
nous avons vu que et déjà eu des
échanges sur le fait que cette
expérimentation elle allait conduire sur
une véritable évaluation qui permettra
d'éclairer législateur pour savoir s'il
faut pérenniser ou non ce système de
vidéoprotection et que nombre de
garanties ont été mises et introduites
que ce soit un texte original ou que ce
soit par la commission des lois pour que
cette évaluation soit faite de manière
la plus indépendante possible merci
monsieur le ministre
je mets au voile d'amendement 27 qui a
reçu deux avis défavorables qui est pour
qui contre
il n'est pas adopté j'ai été saisie
d'une demande de scrutin ah pardon
monsieur dessus mais pour une
explication de vote sur l'article 7 si
c'est possible merci merci Madame nous
ne considérons pas que les nos libertés
publiques soient sujets à
expérimentation y compris borné dans le
temps nous considérons que cet article
n'a rien à faire dans ce projet de loi
n'en déplaise à monsieur le ministre
nous pensons qu'il est lié plus qu'il
fait plutôt lieu de forme d'opportunisme
sécurité à destiné à maquer à masquer un
centre de défaillance que le ministre a
connu lors de de du fiasco du Stade de
France et donc nous allons nous opposer
à cet article aucune garantie que nous
avons proposé n'ont été acceptés et donc
nous allons basculer via cet article
dans une un nouveau régime de
surveillance donc nous allons voter
contre
[Musique]